[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a una semana en el
mundo del programa de France 24 en el
que los periodistas son los invitados y
Con quienes conversamos de una manera
mucho más distendida sobre algunos de
los hechos más destacados de la semana
para conversar sobre los temas que hemos
seleccionado para este programa
saludamos a illian cedeño ella es
editora de la sección global del
periódico excelsior ilián buenas tardes
Gracias por estar con nosotros
bienvenida Y qué tal termina su semana
buenas tardes Gracias un gusto estar
platicando con ustedes muy bien una
semana muy movida a nivel periodístico y
en materia noticiosa
por supuesto semana con muchos temas y
Aquí vamos solamente hacer una selección
de algunos de ellos destacados de la
semana pero también para conversar sobre
lo que hemos seleccionado para ustedes
está con nosotros Gustavo Sierra
periodista y analista de política
internacional de infobae América Gustavo
se conecta desde la ciudad de Buenos
Aires en Argentina Gustavo bienvenido Y
qué tal termina usted su semana allí en
Argentina con mucho calor Un verano
intenso en Buenos Aires
Terrible y además de todo eso no la
termino tengo que seguir escribiendo
para el periódico para el fin de semana
pero
sí una una semana marcada obviamente por
la guerra en Ucrania y los temas en
América Latina sobre seguridad que nos
están marcando a todos haga calor o esté
nevando como
Así es a Iliana Gustavo les doy entonces
la bienvenida les agradezco por estar en
conexión remota y aquí en el estudio de
France 24 nos acompaña Camilo Gómez
periodista de la sección mundo del
diario El espectador de Colombia Camilo
Bienvenido al programa bienvenido
también al estudio de France 24 y
también usted cómo termina su semana
bueno Muchas gracias Santiago por la
invitación también una semana muy
agitada en materia de asuntos
periodísticos Y pues prepararnos también
para lo que será una semana muy movida
con el aniversario de la muerte del
presidente del expresidente Hugo Chávez
tema que va a estar en la agenda
periodística para los próximos días
Claro que sí pues yo les recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar sus opiniones
sus preguntas y comentarios a través de
las redes sociales estamos como arroba
franz24_esántilogo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta es numeral una
semana en el mundo f24 todo pegado todo
junto para que dejen sus comentarios a
través de las redes sociales comenzamos
entonces en en México este país lo vimos
a lo largo de los últimos días ha
presenciado multitudinarias
manifestaciones ciudadanas en rechazo a
la reforma al Instituto Nacional
electoral INE para algunos sectores de
la sociedad mexicana y también de la
política de ese país la reforma afecta
la democracia pero para el gobierno el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
la reforma este ente electoral es para
hacerlo más eficiente y también para
blindarlo en cierta forma contra la
corrupción la reforma sin duda alguna
genera diversidad de opiniones en ese
país comienzo dándole la palabra
entonces a Elián en Ciudad de México
sobre lo que significa para los
mexicanos esta reforma que ya fue
aprobada y pues ya solamente resta
prácticamente ponerla en marcha allí en
México pero divide aún más a la sociedad
mexicana
Así es bueno Mira desde hace algunas
semanas empezó el movimiento para
mostrar la oposición a esta reforma que
tuvo una propuesta inicial y bueno de
ahí surgió lo que conocemos como el Plan
B ayer se promulgó en el diario oficial
de la federación y hoy entre amigos pero
como bien mencionas hubo mucha queja
mucho posición miles de personas de
concentraron en varias ciudades del país
y en otras ciudades a nivel mundial para
oponerse a esta reforma Pues dicen los
ciudadanos y los partidos de oposición
que viola la Constitución y además de
eso en números nulos al Instituto
Nacional electoral lo cual complicaría
la realización de elecciones por qué lo
comento porque en las reformas que se
mantienen las adecuaciones que se hacen
algunos artículos de la Reforma
electoral pues lo que indica es una
reducción importante en nivel de de
funcionarios queda como la operación la
cantidad de personas que elaborarían en
el instituto y con eso se compromete la
realización adecuada de unos comicios
además se recorta el presupuesto no se
han mencionado tal cual la cantidad cómo
sería pero sí ya se estipuló la
reducción de los salarios para los
comisionado de este instituto en
específico en esto la gente lo que pelea
es la violación a la democracia dicen
que con esto se pone en riesgo el voto Y
aunque el presidente López Obrador
argumenta que con esto se garantiza que
no haya funcionarios corruptos Bueno
pues si pasamos de diez funcionarios en
una
en un consejo distrital a dos que van a
quedar y se compromete bastante la
realización de estos comicios Bueno le
preguntó a Camilo aquí en el estudio de
France 24 para luego cruzar a Gustavo en
Buenos Aires usted ha seguido ha seguido
esta historia a lo largo de los últimos
días Camilo perspectiva de lo que
significa esta reforma Aparentemente
simplemente un proyecto de la
presidencia pero no termina de calar
entre los mexicanos Sí y entiendo
perfectamente porque pues siempre que
hay un cambio en las reglas de juego
pues la gente suele asustarse
con con toda la razón y sobre todo
entiendo mucho los mexicanos porque
Bueno hasta el año 2000 teníamos como
una un partido predominante que era el
pri durante más de siete décadas y el
Instituto Nacional electoral fue una de
de esas instituciones que sirvió para
promover una democracia más estable en
el país y más participativa con otros
partidos que tengamos una reforma
ahorita de este sistema pues es es muy
alarmante para todos y sobre todo creo
que hay argumentos que se caen por su
propio peso el hecho de que el
presidente López Obrador diga que se van
a ahorrar más de 270 millones de dólares
por el cambio en la reducción los
funcionarios pues hay que pagar ciertas
indemnizaciones no y se van a está
previsto que se van a gastar más de 280
millones de dólares en
indemnizaciones de las personas que
trabajan en el INE Entonces pues no va a
haber un ahorro no va a haber becas para
estudiantes como lo promulga el
presidente López Obrador Así que este
argumento que es el principal pues se
cae por su propio peso entiendo mucho la
preocupación de los mexicanos y pues por
eso las reacciones de tantos países como
Estados Unidos frente a este a este
cambio claro y Gustavo para cerrar esta
primera ronda en la ciudad de Buenos
Aires su opinión
bueno en línea ha tenido un papel
preponderante en la los últimos años en
México y por sobre todo para la
democratización o redemocratización de y
los procesos electorales que se dieron
desde el año 2000 entonces aquí no no se
trata de una reforma
simple simple por parte del presidente
amlo sino que esto es parte de lo que
muchos de los presidentes populistas de
el continente están realizando que son
tratar de reformar las instituciones del
estado para
mantenerse en el poder eso es
exactamente lo que quieren hacer y el
INE es incómodo en el momento en que se
quiera realizar cualquier tipo de
maniobra durante unas elecciones en en
México y ya aprobado
es eficiente que ha logrado
trabar alguna de las
innumerables irregularidades que se
producen en las elecciones y otra vez
creo que el presidente López Obrador
está haciendo una reforma innecesaria y
solamente
escudándose detrás de eso para algún
tipo de posibilidad que pueda tener en
el futuro Gustavo continuó con usted
para hacer la ronda la inversa así las
cosas y como ustedes explican el
panorama el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador habría tenido Entonces
al haber sido aprobada esta reforma un
triunfo a nivel político puede ser un
triunfo político pero a nivel de la
sociedad de los votantes de los
mexicanos esto le va a pasar una factura
le van a cobrar al presidente haber
hecho esta reforma era una pregunta que
nos estábamos haciendo algunos
compañeros aquí en la redacción de
France 24 y quería traerla aquí al
programa para conocer su su perspectiva
Gustavo
esto lo que hace es mostrar una vez más
que la sociedad está absolutamente
dividida no solo México sino en buena
parte de los países en América Latina en
Argentina llamamos la grieta y es
simplemente una división política
profunda entre un sector
para para llamarlo de alguna manera
populista que intenta ir por encima de
las estructuras democráticas del estado
y una sociedad que no sabe muy bien cómo
contestar Cómo responder qué hacer y
entonces se producen estas grandes
movilizaciones que
el problema que tienen es que después no
tienen una continuidad no no hay
expresiones políticas después que las
representen y terminamos en el en los
típicos movimientos que también estamos
viendo a raíz de estas movidas que son
los
que se vayan todos basta de política la
antipolítica la extrema derecha o la
extrema izquierda como
respuesta a estas
a esta a esta grieta a estas emisiones
profundas pero que en realidad no se
pueden dirimir concretamente
en políticamente y que se van a dirimir
finalmente en las urnas pero son las que
están marcando este periodo tan
particular en el mundo en esta era de lo
impensable de lo imprevisible Además que
si miramos no solamente en México sino
en diferentes países estos reclamos
ciudadanos se quedan en eso en marchas
en reclamos en solicitudes en pedidos y
no todos los gobiernos prestan atención
o escuchan estos reclamos o por lo menos
se sientan
a conversar y a entender que lo que
están pidiendo los ciudadanos paso a
preguntarle a Elián ya le doy la palabra
a Camilo ahí lean Quiero conocer su su
opinión Ileana esto es un triunfo del
presidente López Obrador y estos los
ciudadanos le cobrarán esta por lo menos
no escucharlos porque las
manifestaciones han sido multitudinarias
las imágenes que nos llegaban de la
manifestación en el Zócalo en la Ciudad
de México eran bastante impresionantes
Considero que desde hace tiempo ya se le
está cobrando factura al presidente
López Obrador pero como Bien dicen hay
una división muy marcada en el país
Bueno a nivel regional pero aquí en
México Esta división se ha expresado en
varios de los de las iniciativas de las
medidas que ha presentado el partido en
el poder sin embargo esta movilización
como mencionaban no tiene una cara un
liderazgo entonces corremos el riesgo de
que se pierda precisamente y también hay
otro punto hoy mismo empezó ya la
batalla legal varios partidos
presentaron tienen treinta días para
impugnar esta reforma el Plan B de la
Reforma electoral Y entonces todavía
tenemos treinta días para ver cuánto hay
expide y afloje tanto de la oposición
como del oficialismo Y sí sí creo que el
reflejo se verán las urnas en las
próximas elecciones pero también ya
veremos el impacto de esta reforma
electoral Entonces sí Considero que
desde ahorita el presidente con este
reclamo multitudinario ya está viendo
que muchos de los que votaron hace unos
años por él Ahorita salieron a
manifestarse en contra de su propia
medida y aquí en el estudio de France 24
Camilo para el cierre de esta ronda
opinión Yo creo que el presidente López
Obrador puede estar subestimando el la
capacidad de las marchas y tenemos un
ejemplo muy reciente que fue el que pasó
en Estados Unidos en 2020 con Donald
Trump que siguió las mismas prácticas
de financió el sistema de electoral de
Estados Unidos el servicio de correo
también y pues la gente contestó
saliendo a votar en masa y saliendo a
votar en masa contra él López Obrador ha
dicho esta semana que la gente Pues que
marche tenía desestimado también los
números de la gente que salió a marchar
yo creo que no no entender la capacidad
de la gente para sentarse protesta Más
adelante las elecciones de 2024 puede
pasarle factura Usted cree que el
presidente López Obrador está buscando
perpetuarse en el poder o por lo menos
hacer un siguiente mandato así las las
leyes en México no lo permitan o por lo
menos garantizar que su movimiento
morena Va a continuar en el poder con
estas reformas son palabras fuertes pero
sí estaría diciendo eso sobre todo que
hay muchos precedentes en las
declaraciones de López Obrador y en la
forma en que ha conducido por ejemplo
las votaciones para sostenerle al
público que todavía es popular ante
ellos como El bueno la votación que
tuvimos el año pasado Entonces sí hay
varios mecanismos que he usado para
manifestar que su intención es continuar
en el poder la misma pregunta para Elián
y Gustavo comienzo con Gustavo sí o no
para cerrar este bloque de México
Gustavo sí o no el presidente trata de
mantenerse en el poder o por lo menos
que morena se mantenga en el poder
Sí por supuesto es para eso es lo que
está ahí sí su opinión para el cierre
sí al menos el movimiento él ya dijo que
se vaya pero sí es un movimiento quiere
que tome fuerza que se mantenga y aquí
yo preguntaría pero no hay una oposición
que ya tenga un líder que ahorita ya le
haga competencia al presidente no al
menos a los que ya están luciendo como
sus probables relevos de
no tenemos todavía otro líder que haga
contrapeso no lo hay por lo menos no hay
una cara fuerte y desde fuera de las
fronteras mexicanas no lo vemos tampoco
así dejamos el tema de México hasta ahí
hay muchísimos más aristas para analizar
sobre este tema pero tenemos que avanzar
con con otros de los temas de la
selección de la semana y es justamente
el que tiene que ver con los presidentes
de El Salvador y de Colombia que
chocaron a través de sus cuentas de
Twitter por la política carcelaria los
mandatarios también se enfrentaron por
sus respectivos logros digámoslo así en
términos de seguridad cada en cada uno
de sus respectivos
Petro criticó al gobierno de El Salvador
por la construcción de ese penal de
máxima seguridad que alberga a unos
40.000 reos los llamó un campo de
concentración Entonces por supuesto como
tenía que esperarse pues bukele
respondió a través de la mejor forma que
puede hacer y es a través de Twitter son
dos presidentes que se manifiestan y dan
su opinión todo el tiempo a través de
las redes sociales bukele respondió
dando argumentos para defender su
política contra las maras y le dijo a
Petro que los logros van mucho más allá
de La retórica así las cosas Petro ha
tenido ya choques con los mandatarios de
Guatemala del Salvador de Perú en donde
ya es persona no grata y Tal parece que
solamente se toma fotos con boric con el
presidente y boric de chile y con el
presidente maduro de Venezuela comienzo
la ronda con Gustavo preguntándole su
opinión sobre este rifirrafe además a
través de redes sociales público cada
uno sacando lo mejor de sus logros en
materia de
qué se puede decir de este tema en
principio estamos en el segundo en la
segunda década del siglo 21 y en el
medio de una Revolución científico
tecnológica muy importante y hay
controversias que son muy antiguas y
cabezas que piensan muy viejo esto es en
todo el continente más allá de estos dos
presidentes y de esta controversia la
pero que sí obviamente están embarcados
creo que busqué
se monta en algo Que obviamente hay que
hacer y que tenía que hacer que era
terminar con las maras había que
combatirlas y
como se sale de libreto permanentemente
también lo hizo en este tema El una
cárcel de para 40.000 personas es un
absurdo es un campo de concentración
realmente Más allá de la controversia
hay que lo haya dicho el presidente
Petro
no se sabe que va a hacer con estas
personas para qué están ahí
que que va a suceder en todo el tiempo
en que estén en el lugar 40.000 personas
que Obviamente le van a traer una
cantidad grande de problemas entonces
creo que la la raíz de todo esto es que
se hace y cómo se combate al
narcotráfico
al terrorismo y a la y a estos
delincuentes organizados no es fácil la
respuesta no es fácil no
el experimento de bukele todavía lo
tenemos que digerir todavía lo tenemos
que observar pero yo estoy convencido de
que todo hay que hacerlo dentro de los
márgenes democráticos y nada fuera de él
sí y lo que no es Claro todavía este
experimento como usted lo llama Gustavo
es que no se sabe Cuáles van a ser esos
parámetros de reinserción de estas
personas de nuevo en la sociedad
salvadoreña están detenidos están
cumpliendo una condena por delitos que
pueden haber cometido eso por lo menos
dicen aunque hay muchas denuncias
también de personas que arbitrariamente
han sido detenidas pero no hay un plan
para la reinserción O por lo menos no lo
conocemos hasta ahora Camilo su opinión
además que el presidente de su país
Colombia metido en esta controversia y y
pues a todo nivel a través de Twitter sí
Bueno creo que ustedes ya lo resumieron
muy bien son tres ideas que surgen a
partir de este debate sin ánimo de
polinizar la primera es que Petro parece
el presidente Petro Parece ser incapaz
de controlarse a la hora de hablar de
asuntos internos de otro país y miren lo
llamativo que es resulta la la
intervención que hizo en este caso
comienza diciendo a mí te permite hablar
de asuntos de otro país y viene un gran
Pero seguido de dos minutos hablando de
asuntos internos de otro país ya lo hizo
como como mencionaban hace un momento
en en Perú donde ya es persona no grata
lo hizo también en Argentina en el caso
con la presidenta Cristina Fernández de
kirchner enfrentándose a la justicia lo
hizo también en Chile después de los
resultados de la Constituyente y llama
mucho la atención que si su intención
era hablar sobre Derechos Humanos no se
pronuncie bueno la semana pasada ya fue
cambiando un poco el discurso sobre lo
que ocurre en Nicaragua o más
puntualmente en Venezuela la segunda
idea también Es sobre el problema que
tenemos con la personalización del
debate político antes eran eh los medios
de comunicación los que ponían la agenda
Y ahora resulta que los medios estamos
corriendo a esa personalización de de
las ideas políticas en una plataforma
como Twitter en donde los debates se dan
entre dos figuras y no a nivel de
institución de estado sino de las mismas
persona estuviesen los medios de
comunicación yo por ejemplo estaba
corriendo porque hablaba Petro y no
tenía que decirle el registro y luego
hablaba bukele y así continuamente
nosotros nos volvemos prácticamente una
caja de resonancia entonces habría que
revisar también cómo estamos
participando ahí y la última idea es que
pues si bien uno puede estar
no puede estar totalmente de acuerdo con
lo que hizo Petro en la manera en la que
lo hizo si es muy preocupante lo que
está haciendo bukele y los organismos
internacionales deberían estar siguiendo
con más cuidado pues lo que estaba
ocurriendo en las prisiones de El
Salvador y bueno caja de resonancia Pues
bueno estamos debatiendo eso el día de
hoy en el programa acá no estamos
comentando Y lean ya le voy a dar la
palabra y sí no es un pronunciamiento
oficial a través de las cancillerías o a
través de organismos internacionales son
simplemente opiniones personales que
bueno también está Sí está bien ese
debate por parte de los medios de
comunicación de que tanto peso le damos
a estos comentarios en las redes
sociales Y lean su opinión sobre este
tema
Sí bueno como mencionan al final en la
era Trump se designó Twitter como el
portavoz oficial no de todo lo lo
gubernamental sin embargo también en los
medios de comunicación nos hemos quedado
en este en este rebote de redes sociales
y si escarbamos un poquito y aterrizo en
este tema de la Mega cárcel en El
Salvador Pues sí hubo una reducción en
materia de homicidios por ejemplo de
violencia y homicidios desde que abrió
esta
desde que puso el estado de emergencia
pero en esta cárcel todo lo que se ha
filtrado y todo lo que se ha llamado
esta violación a derechos humanos la
integridad de los mismos precios Pues
compete a cada estado Entonces sí
coincidiría en que el presidente Petro
pues está volteando a ver y usando
alguna política para comparar lo que
aplicó en su país no mencionaba que
cuando se hizo una estrategia similar en
Colombia pues tuvo resultados
cuestionables y sí también le contesta
bukele que son dos personas y bukele un
presidente millennial que aterriza luego
luego en retomar no publicaciones y
Mostrar que justamente hubo una
deficiencia ya y entre televisión
Yo me estoy ocupando lo mío pero quién
está interviniendo ahí quién está
mediando tenemos ahorita muchas
instituciones y organismos
internacionales centrados en la guerra
centrados en Estados Unidos que es el
foco permanente y también en Perú no
ahorita lo estamos viendo y quién se
está asegurando justamente Cómo se está
trabajando Este programa para sacar a
las pandillas de las calles y entonces
el debate queda en qué le dijo uno al
otro y no en el fondo de lo que están
diciendo Claro que esta mega cárcel al
final va a quedar en una estrategia
político mediática claramente y también
estas críticas van desde un país que
todavía no ha resuelto muchos temas de
violencia Colombia a pesar de que ha
mejorado algunas de sus cifras de
violencia sigue siendo un país muy
violento y con muchas deficiencias de
presencia de estado en zonas Rurales
donde prácticamente quien ejerce allí la
actividad del Estado son grupos
delincuenciales o grupos cercanos al
narcotráfico o guerrillas y bueno la
realidad colombiana pues no es no es lo
que vamos a debatir acá pero pero pues
uno tiene que entrar a criticar cuando
tiene algo para mostrar y tal vez lo de
Colombia no es como lo más reluciente
que podamos salir a mostrar en términos
de seguridad para el cierre quiero
hablar de ese liderazgo que intenta
construir el presidente Petro ilián de
la izquierda de en Latinoamérica muchos
dicen que un poco a la sombra de Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva que ya es un líder
Pues de esta tendencia política después
de dos periodos presidenciales en Brasil
pero cómo construyó un liderazgo a nivel
regional cuando lo que haces es meterte
a criticar
las políticas de los otros países
es poco no se puede entender claramente
Cuál es la estrategia a nivel
internacional de Petro
Bueno también hay que ver un punto mucha
gente sigue respondiendo a esto lo mismo
y lo mencionaban no solo ocurra en
Colombia ocurre en México ocurre en
varios países que están gobernados
ahorita Por la izquierda en en América
Latina Qué pasa sigue respondiendo mucha
gente a este discurso contestatario a
este discurso en el que no es de datos
duros no es un discurso presidencial de
datos duros sino de debate de
confrontación y hay gente que responde a
ello y lo vemos tanto en Colombia como
en México como en el mismo Venezuela
como sigue habiendo personas que no
escudriñan en estos datos Y en el ver
que realmente este Y entonces para Petro
le está funcionando de alguna manera
pero también le está funcionando avanzar
en equipo ahorita vemos ese liderazgo
que en algún momento empezó a asumir a
nivel regional Andrés Manuel López
Obrador Petro la y él van ahorita en
conjunto pero ninguno está un avance en
claro
retoma el poder y también bueno regresa
al poder y también está mostrando querer
ahí avanzar y limpiar todo lo que dejó
eh bolsonaro pero nunca un líder uno que
esté avanzando Y entonces viene esta
competencia como Bien dicen del
populismo sí no brilla alguien más
entonces mientras uno avance vamos a
estar viendo este entre estos líderes
que están intentando tomar
pues vamos a ver en qué termina esta
disputa mediática tuitera entre estos
dos presidentes claramente Esto no se va
a terminar aquí esto ya quedó encendido
ahí un escenario de confrontación y de
críticas a nivel de Twitter y
seguramente veremos más choques entre
los dos rápidamente pasamos de tema y
nos vamos a hablar de un fallo histórico
de la Corte Suprema de Panamá que
rechazó reconocer el matrimonio
igualitario en ese país el ente público
lo consideró no es un derecho humano
reconocido y que tampoco es reconocido
por la Constitución de Panamá la corte
Indicó que es legítimo el reclamo por
parte de los diferentes colectivos que
presentaron esta propuesta y que han
estado empujando para que haya una
aprobación por parte del legislativo
pero no tiene categoría de derecho
humano o fundamental en ese país
solamente se reconoce el matrimonio
entre un hombre y una mujer comienzo
entonces aquí en el estudio de France 24
en Bogotá comenzó con Camilo opiniones
sobre este tema que no sé si usted tiene
la impresión que poco cubrimiento
mediático ha tenido esta decisión en
Panamá sí es verdad muy poco cubrimiento
mediático a pesar de la importancia
categórica para la región especialmente
para Centroamérica en donde solo Costa
Rica permite el matrimonio igualitario
pero es particularmente llamativo en el
caso de Panamá que es una nación
relativamente joven en materia de
reconocimiento de los derechos para la
comunidad
hasta 2008 reconocieron que era legal
mantener relaciones entre personas del
mismo sexo y hay una gran gama de
de acciones que no son permitidas para
los miembros de esta comunidad como
donar sangre como participar de las
fuerzas militares entre otras cosas
Entonces sí hubo particularmente yo creo
que estuvo marcado por los otros asuntos
de la agenda que se llevaron como la
confrontación entre bukele y Petro pero
es un tema que sí vale la pena
desarrollarse sobre todo también por la
influencia de de la iglesia en Panamá
que no ha permitido pues avances en esta
materia paso a preguntarle a Gustavo en
la ciudad de Buenos Aires me gustaría
conocer su opinión sobre este tema sobre
todo viniendo de un país que tiene
tantas políticas y ha sido uno de los de
los líderes en la región de América
Latina en cuanto a establecer derechos
para la comunidad lgbti y bueno Y para
otro tipo de de políticas para otras
minorías sí Y creo que tenemos que
volver a esto que te comentaba antes del
pensar viejo no de estar fuera de la
realidad del Siglo 21
y esto es lo que sucede en Panamá y lo
que sucede muchos otros lugares y es no
entender que un chico de cualquier
Barrio
Pobre de cualquiera de nuestros países
tiene un teléfono y o lo compró o lo
compró robado o lo rogó pero lo tiene y
por lo tanto está conectado con la
realidad de lo que sucede globalmente no
ya no se mueve con la realidad de ese
pequeño
de esa de esa pequeña esfera que quieren
plantear muchos en
algunos países y entonces no entender
realmente lo que está sucediendo y el
cambio profundo que se está produciendo
en nuestras sociedades Entonces
no
aprobar este tipo de
iniciativas o de retrasarlas o de lo que
sea realmente es estar fuera de la de lo
que piensa la gente de lo que está
viviendo la gente cualquier chico
entiende que
en cualquier lugar del mundo ya los
géneros de la misma manera que Los
conocíamos hace hasta hace 50 o 100 años
atrás o de la manera en que queríamos
imponerlo Perdón
no funcionan más y ellos mismos no lo
reconocen en sus relaciones por lo tanto
Son son algunas acciones muy retrógradas
que no tienen validez y que no van a
tener
no van a ser rebotadas por las nuevas
generaciones y se habla de unos valores
familiares pero es que también el
concepto de familia ha cambiado mucho a
lo largo de los años y se mantienen
valores dentro de un nuevo concepto de
familia y unos nuevos valores acomodados
o ajustados a la realidad actual eso
también hay que verlo en perspectiva
sobre este tema Y lean su opinión sobre
este tema para ir cerrando de avanzar
Sí coincido con Gustavo
es ir en contra de la sociedad
internacionales y en contra de Casi ya
cuarenta países que su legislación
nacional permite el matrimonio
igualitario y lo avala como legal es
voltear a la realidad y querer
enfrascarse en la visión de seis de
nueve magistrados porque en Panamá seis
nueve Pues votaron en contra Entonces
en dónde recaen la decisión en donde
recae todo un año de debate que tuvieron
la decisión de que es probable o no que
es avalable no entonces
la sociedad para mañana con justa razón
está peleando por sus derechos y en qué
momento como mencionas tú en qué momento
se está mezclando la calidad moral y los
valores que se han transformado son la
visión de seis de nueve personas que
toman estas decisiones y creo que está
poniendo mucho riesgo y mucho en juego
la Corte Suprema de Panamá
manifestándose en contra de lo que ya
Está avanzando porque bueno menciona 36
países pero avalan a nivel nacional pero
también hay decenas de países que a
niveles locales Claro en materia
legislativa lo permiten entonces
de la marea sí no en contra de la marea
pero hay que decir que esto no es una
moda es simplemente se le está dando un
reconocimiento a unas minorías que
anteriormente estaban siendo
invisibilizadas dado el contexto en el
que estaban las sociedades en ese
momento llegamos al bloque final de el
programa y tenemos que hablar de El
diario La prensa uno de los más
emblemáticos de la prensa nicaragüense
cumplió 97 años de su fundación es muy
paradójico que este medio de
comunicación tenga que celebrar su
aniversario con toda su redacción en el
exilio sus instalaciones Fueron
expropiadas por el gobierno del
presidente Daniel Ortega el diario ha
calificado su situación actual como muy
complicada tal vez la más difícil de su
historia las instalaciones como decía
fueron buscadas sus recursos materiales
también fueron confiscados tres de sus
propietarios y directivos fueron
desterrados también despojados de la
ciudadanía nicaragüense después de haber
estado mucho tiempo empírido en prisión
y parte de sus periodistas también están
en el exilio el diario que está a punto
de cumplir un siglo Son 97 años Ahora
tiene que enfocar toda su actividad
periodística en internet no puede hacer
presencia de modo impreso como lo fue
durante muchos años comienzo por ilian
en México perspectiva de esta censura
mediática en Nicaragua lo que ha
sucedido porque no es solamente el único
medio que ha sido afectado por la
censura del presidente Ortega también
hay otras radios y televisiones y otros
medios digitales también
Sí en especial en México se le está
dando mucha atención al tema de
Nicaragua porque como mencionamos
previamente Pues el nuestro gobierno ha
opinado al respecto no al respecto de
todo lo que también y bueno en el diario
La prensa la lo que está viviendo la
expulsión como bien menciona de sus
colaboradores y más de 300 personas que
se vieron afectadas por estas medidas de
Daniel Ortega Pues sí recaen a nivel
internacional y generan una preocupación
tanto así que llegó a la ONU y ayer
acusó al presidente Daniel Ortega de
crímenes de lesa humanidad estamos
hablando de un tema que escaló bastante
al grado de
ciertas acusaciones y declaraciones pero
que no le hacen ella al presidente
Ortega el presidente Ortega parece
avanzar
con sus ideas fijas y bueno los
opositores en Nicaragua están
enfrentando el cobijo están recibiendo
el cobijo de muchos de otros países
mucho ya aceptaron nacionalidad pero yo
me pregunto y los que están en Nicaragua
que están viviendo este que no tienen
otra opción que acatar pues las órdenes
y lo que está buscando el presidente
Ortega en un régimen que no pregunta
sino que ordena Entonces yo sí
consideraría que ahorita los que están
fuera de Nicaragua ya tienen ese
respaldo de muchas naciones y llegó
hasta la ONU pero hay que voltear a ver
a los que están ahí no tienen otra
opción Claro que someterse a los Ortega
Murillo No sí Y aquí en el estudio de
France 24 Camilo su opinión Bueno es muy
triste para la sociedad nicaragüense
poder despertar un día y no tener acceso
a un periódico impreso Hace poco hablé
con el ex embajador de Nicaragua ante
ante Naciones Unidas y él me comentaba
precisamente eso que ya en su papel en
su país no podía conseguir un solo
periódico impreso han sido más de 50
medios cerrados por él por el gobierno
de Daniel Ortega y Va a continuar así
como como decía mi colega Pues está
encaminado a continuar ejerciendo
mecanismos para atornillarse al poder y
es momento de que a través de los
mecanismos
multinacionales que tenemos aquí en la
región los presidentes Aquí sí puedan
hacer frente a lo que está ocurriendo en
Nicaragua y haber un llamado atención
porque pues las sanciones hasta ahora
han sido poco productivas Gustavo su
opinión para el cierre me queda un
minutico rápidamente y muy puntual por
favor
la primera es la censura es imposible
hoy otra vez el telefonito Claro en
principio y luego
Obviamente que no va a poder de ninguna
manera terminar con la oposición la
oposición se va a seguir manifestando y
el diario La prensa lo va a seguir
diciendo a través del medio que sea
tecnológico por último esta semana
escribí una nota sobre preguntándome
sobre la salud mental de las personas
que tienen el poder y yo creo que en el
caso de Ortega y Murillo tendríamos que
preguntarnos si alguien que quiere tener
un trabajo en un supermercado tiene que
pasar un examen psicológico cómo es
posible que haya gente de este tipo que
llega al poder Claro sin que nadie sepa
Cuál es su verdadera Salud Mental
pues hay que esa pregunta Gustavo ileani
Camilo aquí en el estudio les agradezco
por haber estado con nosotros también
pues desde acá desde France 24 nuestra
solidaridad con los colegas periodistas
nicaragüenses que tienen que ejercer su
profesión en condiciones muy difíciles
muchos de ellos En el exilio el
ejercicio de la prensa debe ser
completamente libres es tal vez el
mensaje la reflexión para el cierre del
programa ustedes pueden seguir dejando
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales sigan con nuestra
programación
[Música]